it is official the conservatorship of
bernie spears has been terminated
after 13 years the conservatorship which
has ruled over britney spears life and
finances has finally come to an end so
how did we get to this pivotal moment
and what happens now
in november 2006 britney spears filed
for divorce from her then-husband and
the father of her two children kevin
fedeline
the following year spears one of the
biggest stars in the world suffered a
very public mental health breakdown
up until this point britney's image had
been carefully controlled
am i a virgin
in 2007 shortly after entering rehab for
drug abuse spears walked into a los
angeles hair salon and shaved her head
in february 2008 the 26 year old singer
was taken to hospital for a psychiatric
evaluation for the second time this is
when britney's father jamie spears asked
a los angeles court to put britney in a
temporary emergency conservatorship
later that year a judge extended
contemporary conservatorship
indefinitely
[Music]
britney's conservatorship was split into
two parts one for her estate so her home
her credit card her finances and the
other for her person so her health and
well-being when britney's
conservatorship was granted in 2008 a
judge said that it was in britney's best
interests and stated that britney was
susceptible to undue influence
it meant that britney's father jamie was
given the legal right to make decisions
regarding his daughter's finances health
business deals and personal life britney
was stripped of her rights
a conservatorship is granted by a court
for individuals who are unable to make
their own decisions so those for
instance who are suffering with dementia
or another mental illness it's intended
for those who cannot take care of
themselves
[Music]
the free britney movement was formed by
britney spears fans who were concerned
about the true nature of her
conservatorship and wanted the singer to
be free
fans began to look for clues as to how
britney might be feeling in her
instagram photos and videos
next question is am i okay yes i'm
totally fine
i'm taking a break right now because um
i'm enjoying myself
while it's been going on for several
years now the free britney movement
gained real momentum in 2021 thanks to a
documentary to unsealed court documents
and britney's own testimony
britney's thanked the movement for
raising awareness of her conservatorship
battle and even posted this video with
fiance samasgari
after years of near silence on the issue
earlier this year britney spears issued
a 24-minute statement against the
conservatorship in her testimony she
said that her father and others forced
her to work tirelessly she compared her
seven day a week working schedule to
slavery since the establishment of her
conservatorship britney has released
four albums she's been a judge on the
second season of the x factor and
performed for four years in a hit las
vegas residency
britney spears told a u.s judge she's
been prevented from getting married or
having children and has been prescribed
medication against her will she called
the arrangement abusive and said she was
traumatized
not only is this momentous for brittany
but she helped shine a light
on conservatorships and guardianships
from coast to coast
britney's lawyer has vowed to
investigate britney's father for alleged
financial misdeeds he questions how much
money jamie has received from the
conservatorship since the arrangement
began
jamie spears says he has nothing to hide
regarding his administration of
britney's estate and will therefore hide
nothing
he maintains that he loves his daughter
wants to protect her and her best
interests he says he has never abused
her
while this is a key moment it's not the
final chapter in this story britney
spears lawyer has vowed to fight to find
the full depths of how her
conservatorship operated for so long
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]